what's nice is that they made a little
costume adjustment so your boobs are out
I am Ali Hayes I'm an adult film star we
don't have the same job but we do spell
Ali the same way yeah I'm Danny wild I'm
Paris Kennedy and I'm Connor and we're
gonna watch Connors movie it's called
after the heist it's called on my dirty
knees I don't like watching my own
importance it's probably gonna be a
little uncomfortable for me and I've met
Connor before I've never seen one of
your movies so maybe I'm a bad friend
this is a star wars xxx and I play
Princess Leia's but let me just say you
really look like everybody's favorite
part is this amusing and you're like on
the tag it's called free hotdogs yes I
want to go to the roller rink for free
hotdogs but then he stops me a hotdog
you sir a new god we have a lot already
happening on the screen not a lot of
cutaways just a single shot of the tits
and the vagina are you guys good friends
yes oh good that makes it more
comfortable so you literally just met
her before you did this yeah are you
ever nervous yeah before everything wait
so did you all do a heist I only read
the parts to the script that I was in so
this goes on for a while do you remember
at all what could be going through your
mind during things like this where
should I go for food I think I'm more
awkward than you are what's the theater
doing this whole times right now I'm
blowing him to get out of prison
see that's a backstory I could have used
his penis is enormous yeah what else how
big my hand is looks like three of my
spec just went from here to like here we
are in a third base now I guess you
would call it oh just keep it going all
right there's there's some sex I really
wanted my roller skates to like roll
that's a skill though like to do that
and roll I'm trying to concentrate on
what you're saying but like I'm
concentrating on the butcher I forgot
that the penis like flops like like
bounces like one of the things that
stops the door when you open it more
things are happening because there's two
men you guys get it is a lot of this
acting or is this how you're actually
feeling pretty sure this more or less
unfold than naturally anything we're
saying is just
ad-lib look I actually really love doing
it like this is all genuine no you have
to perform yeah and like I really
actually like it I'm like not a faker
it's like I'm like with my partner and
I'm like you will make me come today I'm
sure they listen so you're hearing my it
sounds I'm surprised that like how
comfortable the socks are just a great
touch my only thought here honestly is
like you must have such strong legs do
you like watching yourself are you like
you're just like for your own pleasure
watch yourself it's okay I probably with
you this is the money shot
did it happen did I miss it no oh no
your cups
you shouldn't have to clean up after it
he should Jimmy's a really comfortable
she's lovely it was hard for me to be
like oh that's you and that's you I'm
like oh god don't look you did a really
good job this was so cool you have a
whole new perspective that's like an
educational thing for me right now I'm
just so impressed with how many squats
you can probably I don't think I've ever
watched porn with somebody else so I'm
glad that it was with the person who was
in the video well thank you for watching
my part thank you for letting me watch
it with you
[Music]
I don't know how I go back to work after
this